he's been called the godfather of
activist investing corporate boards make
all Carl Icahn something very different
according to activists insight Icahn ran
14 public campaigns last year and he's
been doing this for a long time in the
1980s Icahn doubled his money on Texaco
in the 90s he made 800 million dollars
on Nabisco and he hasn't lost his touch
just last year his bet on Netflix
returned more than 400 percent new
activists have been as busy or
controversial as Bill Ackman this week
Ackman disclosed the nine point seven
percent stake in Botox maker allergen
and in an unprecedented move for a hedge
fund manager he's teaming up with
valiant pharmaceuticals to buy the whole
company of course there's his notorious
short on Herbalife so far it's been a
wrong-way bet but the one billion-dollar
trade may be turning his way after a 27
percent plunge in Herbalife shares this
year in 2002 he shorted bought insurer
MBIA
saying it didn't deserve a triple-a
rating the financial crisis proved him
right and he made more than a billion
dollars for his clients
dan Loeb rocked Silicon Valley by buying
a 5% stake in Yahoo pretty soon he and
two allies were on the board and
Google's Marissa Mayer was brought in as
CEO
less than two years later Loeb sold a
stake back to Yahoo his profit roughly a
hundred and thirty percent Nelson Peltz
likes consumer products he's taken
stakes in Wendy's and Mondelez the snack
maker but his biggest score came was
Snapple in 1997 Phelps bought Snapple
for 300 million dollars he added new
products and juiced up the ad campaign
just three years later pelt sold Snapple
the price almost one and a half billion
dollars